this is lucy james reading for author
jordan remain rainbow six extraction is
weeks away and ahead of its launch we
got to go hands-on with the game and
here are our impressions for more on
rainbow six extraction make sure to like
this video and subscribe now back in
november ubisoft montreal boasted that
rainbow six extraction would feature
maps that are roughly three times the
size of those found in rainbow six siege
having now spent a good six hours
playing the game i can confirm that yes
extraction does feature some
substantially larger maps in comparison
to its pvp predecessor but i was also
surprised to see that the layouts of
extractions maps are so horizontal in
comparison to those found in siege where
verticality plays a large role in both
map design and navigation to be fair i
only managed to play on maps located in
san francisco and new york in extraction
several of rainbow's operators are
recruited to join a special team tasked
with combating the parasitic alien
archaean threat that spread throughout
north america that mission takes you to
four different zones each of which are
divided into three maps and each of
those maps in turn are cut into three
separate regions so for example the san
francisco zone is split into the
tenderloin enterprise space foundation
and apollo casino and resort maps
rainbow six extraction creative director
patrick matey told me that each zone of
the game has its own flavor and pointed
to alaska as an example where the maps
feature a little bit more verticality he
said in alaska there's some old barns
where you can have line of sight and
have a good vantage point that you can
exploit to either scan the area or just
to down enemies and granted the scenes
of alaska's three maps do seem to be a
bit more open than the enclosed spaces
found in new york and san francisco with
opportunities to shoot down on enemies
from a higher vantage point but
navigating those vertical spaces seems
to be limited to staircases and ladders
just like in new york and san francisco
the grapple gear that siege attack
operators can utilize to scale walls and
swing through windows isn't present in
extraction and the game or at least a
launch doesn't feature any of the
operators that can use their unique
gadgets to navigate vertical spaces such
as amaroo the archaeans don't seem to
move along a vertical plane either they
can move up and down stairs but not once
in my six hours with the game did i ever
have to worry about an archaean crashing
through the ceiling or climbing up from
a lower floor and bursting through a
window every enemy seemed to move along
a horizontal plane it's an altogether
very different sensation from that of
playing siege where you need to consider
that an attack can come from almost any
direction at any time and you can
similarly move about the map in any
number of ways to flank your opponent
extraction instead creates its tension
by limiting your own movement and
pulling you against overwhelming numbers
the threat isn't that you may not see
your enemies attack until it's too late
it's that you almost always can see it
and you just might not be adequately
equipped for it forcing you to consider
alternative strategies like retreating
and drawing enemies into a bottleneck
i never managed to find a place on any
of the maps i played however where i
could easily mow down every enemy in a
level no single plan worked reliably any
strategy my allies and i came up with
would prove effective for a while but
the arkhans would wise up after a few
seconds and we'd have to then adapt to
them so as much as i miss the need to
consider that an attack can come from
anywhere i did appreciate that
extraction tries to make up for that by
stacking the odds numbers-wise against
you maintaining siege's encouragement to
take a stealthy approach to combat mate
says we tried to limit as much as
possible the places where the player
could exploit the ai for example there
are almost no dead ends there's always
at least a minimum of two different
paths that you can take so as a player
that means you cannot just camp at a
place and wait for the enemies because
at some point they will attack you from
behind mate added that the maps in
extraction have three times the amount
of destructible surfaces as those found
in siege increasing the likelihood of
being able to flank or get flanked from
the sides mate said one of the elements
that will be critical to success is
knowing the maps knowing the
opportunities that are available via
destructible walls that you can exploit
to help you accomplish this task every
operator comes equipped with a react
light which illuminates the
bioluminescence of enemies through walls
mate said it allows you to scan an area
without the enemy being able to detect
you and from there you can coordinate
your attack with your teammates and very
efficiently clear a room in a few
seconds without going into a full-blown
firefight and risk broadcasting your
location the idea of that is intriguing
but it doesn't feel authentic to what i
experienced during my preview though
there were multiple opportunities to
attack enemies through walls there
weren't many ways to breach through
walls engage a room of enemies from
multiple sides or clear rooms in one
strategic push unless the squad had
multiple operators on hand with shotguns
as their primary weapon or gadgets
designed for destroying walls like
siege's grapple gear breaching charges
are absent from extraction so if you
don't have someone like sledge or hibana
on the squad you're not breaking down
many walls sure you can shoot through
them or give up a valuable item slot to
carry explosive grenades that can blow
up sections of wall but there's no way
to do a coordinated breach into a room
and clear out every enemy unless teams
pick certain operators between the loss
of vertical navigation and no way to
regularly destroy the environment and
create new pathways extraction feels
like it loses a core part of siege's dna
that helps that game stand out from
other first-person shooters to the
developers credit ubisoft montreal isn't
trying to design extraction to replace
siege or be the next siege it instead
wants the two games to exist side by
side without cannibalizing each other's
player bases but since extraction
utilizes three-person squads instead of
siege's five-person teams there are more
opportunities for you to run with a
squad in extraction that doesn't have
someone who can reliably breach through
walls and without that extraction feels
like a lot of other squad based pve
shooters where you take on hordes of
enemies albeit with a bit more stealth
focused gameplay i asked matey why
ubisoft went with three-person squads
for extraction as opposed to something
larger like what's found in siege and
the answer surprised me i expected
ubisoft montreal was trading on the
variety that a five-person team could
offer for the likely easier to balance
three-person dynamic fewer folks on a
team fewer variables to consider but no
ubisoft montreal shrunk the team size to
cut down on chaotic chat coordination
was lost as soon as teams were expanded
to four players mate said right from the
beginning we started to work with a pve
experience in mind that was the goal of
extraction and then we did some tests to
make sure that since we wanted to make a
tactical pve game which is not the same
as most shooters out there that are more
like a horde mode when you shoot down
hundreds of enemies per level the three
operators was this sweet spot more than
that it very quickly became less chaotic
in larger teams one of your teammates is
always getting detected and it increases
the chances that someone isn't following
the plan just in terms of communication
you end up with people shouting on top
of each other and it becomes a bit of a
blur so we felt that the three player
squad was the most efficient it's an
understandable drawback to consider but
one that i feel has limited what
extraction could be right at the jump a
squad of three can't split up as often
as a team of five if you want to ensure
you're always within the vicinity of
someone who can break through walls
siege was built around the idea of
approaching a single problem through a
multitude of ways a stratagem that
doesn't seem to fully translate to
extraction's core gameplay loop in siege
even if your attack operator didn't
possess a unique gadget geared towards
breaching you could equip breaching
charges and still open new pathways of
attack and navigation extraction doesn't
have that and it's so limiting i noticed
that i wasn't having as much fun when i
wasn't playing as someone like hibana
and able to utilize the destructible
environment to my advantage that's my
biggest worry for extraction as we
approach its launch the game has some
cool looking maps that dwarf the size of
those found in siege but without an easy
means of regularly bending that
environment to your will in order to
create new pathways and sight lines it
loses out on what i find most fulfilling
about siege's gameplay maybe in the end
that will be a good thing that keeps
extraction from eating siege's breakfast
but it doesn't feel good to have left
the extraction play sessions wanting to
play more siege instead and it's not
like extraction wasn't fun i had a good
time playing but the player's ability to
regularly shape the environment and
extraction seems to pale in comparison
to siege be sure to like this video if
you enjoyed it and want to see more
videos about rainbow six extraction and
siege let us know in the comments who
you plan on maining in the game and
which operators you think ubisoft
montreal should add in post-launch
seasons we'd love to see oryx or ash
extraction definitely needs more people
who can regularly reach through walls
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you